you wrote a blog post I think a few
years back maybe that mentioned Tim
Burton's 1994 biopic on Ed Wood
excellent film by the way yeah yeah so
you say that that film is really
important because it shows still current
examples of how films get made today any
thoughts I mean you're on a lower level
but you know it in truth like those
budgets back then were massive today you
know like the kind of films that were
getting made or the Roger Corman era of
making films you know it's um one of the
things okay one of the opening scenes of
that movie Ed Wood Christine Jorgensen
story that's what it was it was
basically a transgendered individual
back in the 50s and some rock producer
was making a film about it and so ed
would seize the opportunity walked into
the door set up a meeting with mr. Weiss
and pitched himself as the guy who had
to make the movie and because he was so
enthusiastic because in truth he was a
transvestite but was very secretive
about it and he just understood the
compelling elements of the story that
had to be created bla bla bla bla bla
and then the producers response was more
or less I don't care I need a producer I
need I need a guy who can make a film in
three days and make me a profit that's
all I care about and the reason was is
he already pre-sold theaters and all of
these states and and you know needed a
movie to cater to that he needed a movie
there was so many reels long using old
film terminology that was a certain
budget level that could be shot in a
certain amount of time and he didn't
care the quality he just needed the
product to fill in the gaps of where it
was pre-sold it still happens today it's
no different it's the same concept in
the indie space today of movies get kind
of pre-sold pre-created pre-developed
and then they need writers producers
very creative minded people to put that
together in a short period of time and
make it happen that's the real job of a
creator is creating making things happen
getting from point A to point B quickly
and effectively that's why at the studio
level
major talents get tons of money and they
receive ridiculous sums of money for
screenplays at the studio level because
frankly it takes a lot of work and it's
very very rare talent to be able to
produce that level so that's that's kind
of why it works that way but if you
haven't seen it I mean it for anyone in
the audience who hasn't seen it it's a
great movie very fun and the whole
process throughout you actually learn a
lot of great lessons about the
filmmaking process and even though it's
from the 90s and talking about an era in
the 50s the principles are exactly the
same
it still works the same way and always
will I think what about the Bela Lugosi
character is there any any same concept
it's it's an aging star who frankly was
kind of washed up at the time but it's
the same idea of yeah I think even in
the opening scene that I'm talking about
that was one of the things is that he he
later went back into the office to
secure the job because he'd written a
script in two days and he had Bela
Lugosi who was a star so he basically
said if you if if you need a schmuck who
can get you a movie in three days with a
star maybe make make me crap I forget
how he described it was very good though
and he's basically just like you know
crap with the star that's what it was
called
and that's basically Bela Lugosi was the
star who was at least a decent enough
name that people recognized that
elevated the product just enough so it
became a Bela Lugosi movie you know that
was being distributed at that point and
last but not least his efforts to secure
finance so so meeting the right person
and having to go to certain lengths to
secure financing yeah so I think there's
a massive misconception like when it
comes to financing as I kind of said
movies are incredibly expensive to
produce and people on the writing end
the directing and the producing and who
want to get their work made seem to be
very very good at writing and keeping
budget in mind and they're really good
at creating budgets and all the great
software that exists now but that
getting to that point of how is it going
to be funded that's sort of the cop
gated thing in Atwood and I think the
hopeful thing that a lot of younger
filmmakers hope is that they can just go
to a rich uncle or dentists or all this
other stuff and just pool money together
wherever money comes from and it you can
still get movies off the ground using
that approach at a higher level you know
if you're creating content that's going
to work for platforms out there there
are a lot of entities that will actually
invest the money and get that so it's
it's kind of I don't know I feel like
I'm getting a little lost in it but it's
like it's not as cut and dry it's always
a mystery as to where and how funding
comes together at the indie level
because there's no one way to do it but
the truth is if you're creating content
that actually has placement that
actually already has a spot to fill it
actually already has a room on a shelf
to be placed there are a lot of entities
who are willing to invest the money into
it I mean I think the real answer is if
you're going out there to produce
something you want to produce because
you're passionate about it and you've
not done any real market research or
talked to companies about what the
market wants you're gonna have a really
tough time getting financing if you take
a step back you focus on what the market
needs what it's asking for what
companies are searching for and then you
cater to those needs financing actually
becomes a lot easier because all of a
sudden you know there's a lot of
companies with deep pockets and are
looking to invest the money they're
looking to invest it with stuff that's
going to help their goals
you